[Music]
hello everyone this is my first podcast
and today we're going to talk about the
impact of social
media technology is very helpful makes a
lot of thing easy but like anything in
the world there is soo much of a good
thing and one thing we don't talk about
is what is the right balance of
technology and I would argue that for
many of us it is out of the
balance we know that the chemical
dopamine is released whenever we get a
bank Buzz flash or be from our
phones dopamine is the exact same
chemical that released in alcohol
nicotine or
gambling in other words it can be
addictive if if you left
unbalance a little alcohol is great but
too much alcohol is not that great
technology is wonderful but too much
technology can be very destructive and
destroy our relationships like all
addiction destroy our
relationships and so that one thing
we're both considering is what is the
right
balance if you wake up in the morning
and you check your phone before you say
good morning to your spouse that's a
problem if you have Phantom beeps that's
a problem if you find yourself incapable
of getting through a day without needing
to check your phone that's a problem now
where it gets really dangerous is with
kids well some of them aren't kids
anymore so almost all alcoholist on the
planet discovered alcohol when they were
children when they were very very young
young the only thing we need is the
approval of our parents when we go
through adolesence we now need the
approval from our peers frustrating for
our parents very important for us
because it allows us to accelerate
outside of immediate families into a
larger
group very stressful time and we're
supposed to learn in this time of
anxiety to rally on our friends to reach
out to our friends for help help that's
we're supposed to
learn some people quite by accident
discovered alcohol and they learn the
numbing effects of dopamine actually
help them get through the stress of
adolesence this connection unfortunately
becomes hardwired and so far the rest of
their lives when they face any kind of
financial career or social stress they
don't turn into a person they turn to a
bottle
so when they suffer stress it turn to a
person and what they do they turn to a
device and what the only does is
increase sense of insolution and
loneliness and can actually destroy
relationships we've all had the
experience where you were where you were
somebody walking down the street out for
dinner or whatever and they pull out
their phone and you feel like like an
idiot now take the entire generation
that has no memory of the time before
the
device they at least can reference time
before cell phone and internet or social
media they at least had a point of
reference we
don't that's how we feel so we have an
entire generation growing up with an
addiction we're seeing increased rates
suicide amongst the
generation we're seeing overdose
generation hom sides school
shootings we're seeing the effect of
loneliness and isolution we're seeing it
yeah and we're not reacting it we're not
doing anything about
it and parents parents are a lot to
blame for this because parents there are
some school who want to restrict phones
in their school and is the parents who
demand that they can keep their phone in
case of
emergency seriously when was the last
time the cell phone was used for
emergency so combined with that fact
that we have an addicted generation that
doesn't give the skill set to ask for
help combined with that fact they're so
good at Facebook and Instagram they're
good at uding filters on everything so
they're good at showing you how smart
and strong they are these kids who
commit suicide you go look at their
Instagram you would have no clue that
they were depressed because they're
happy and truly
starlets their parents told them they
they were special they can get whatever
they want they can get whatever they
need these kids get to get to honors
classes not because they deserve it but
because the parents compl expained and
some of them get good grades not because
they earned it but because the teachers
didn't want to deal with
that and they graduate to college get a
job and in an instant way they find out
they're not special they don't get
anything for coming unless the parents
can get them a promotion and you can
have whatever you want just because you
want it and in an instant way their
entire self imagine is shattered
and you have an entire generation
growing up with a lower confidence than
previous
generation combined with an ability to
ask for help with things that you're
struggling with and you turn into a
social media or a
device you keep checking and checking
you count your followers you count your
likes and somebody unfriends you oh my
God that's a trauma
right what we don't understand is that
life that relationship and career full
of man are a journey there is no app for
that we got to go through the slow
plotting annoying Meandering process
called Career
life but if they don't get it in 8
months they go look it for someone else
if we don't get it we go look it for
someone else it's impatient and because
we didn't have the skill set to ask for
help and because we feel lonely only it
compounds and
compounds parents have to in
turn they have to stop giving their kids
free access to social media and phones
of
course kids are not ready for their
mind their mind can't cope with dopamine
balance is fine you can get a kid of
phone but they can't use it in their
bedroom they can have it at dinner
dinner table they can take you to school
you can allow them to keep for 1 hour
but you must take it
away
now let's get back to positive way of
social media social media can make it
easy to find groups of like-minded
people or make new friends finding a
close need Community can help us feel
valued and accepted social media is also
an easy way of nature existing
relationship
with families and friends who has moved
away I mean send message photos call to
stay in
touch social media has a lot of benefits
for example better communication social
media is known for bringing up new
topics while many conversation may seem
to controversial and
divisive they can bring up important
things to discuss with people you care
about and trust you can also join groups
and spec for specific Hobbies or
introduce to engage of discussion learn
and grow we also have streading news
building a
business driving traffics to your
website learning and
education and yeah social media has a
lot of things that you can use it for
good
so yeah this is the impact of social
media that has positive ways and
negative ways thank you for
[Music]
listening